I don't want you to think about here is
the particular case where I don't
multiply by I don't multiply two
different complex numbers but what if we
multiplied the same complex number
repeatedly okay so let's let's just come
up with this guy so here's your generic
complex number in bought art form okay
using this principle of multiplying the
moduli and adding the arguments right
what's is that square first we'll do you
the moduli yeah
don't go too hard on yourself okay I
hold on a sec I've multiplied the moduli
right hard times on now I add the
arguments right now if I'm adding the
argument to itself theta plus theta it's
just gonna be cos 2 theta plus I sine 2
theta okay with that
now what if I did it again okay if I
multiply by Z the original one another
time okay will I multiply by the same
modulus so I get aa cubed and then I add
the same argument which is still feed on
right so this guy's gonna be cos 3 theta
plus I sine 3 theta okay
now it doesn't take a rocket scientist
to generalize from here right if you
take any complex number and you raise it
to some integer power okay I'm gonna
write down my condition my restriction
in the center if I raise it to an
integer power and all I need to do is
raise the modulus to that same integer
power and multiply my angle by whatever
power it was okay now don't read out
it's not a double and that's by sign
Athena and sometimes to make that really
obvious some some mathematicians and
authors and textbooks will put brackets
around there just to make it really
really obvious now you remember I said
the the complex plane right we call it
beep Argand diagram Anya was a French
mathematician another French
mathematician came up with this now this
is the name I'm gonna put on this okay
and I'm going to write it first and then
I'm gonna teach you how to pronounce it
okay so here's the theorem now I have
heard like a hundred different
pronunciations of of this name okay let
me teach you first like the pieces
before we before we do this thing okay
firstly remember it's French
right it's French so in French when you
see this word what do you say you say
look right you know me okay you do not
say boy secondly when you see this okay
now um you might know there's a famous
art gallery which has this as the Endo's
game as well it's this archaea it's not
quite like we say ah this nerd is third
Valley okay so the way you would say
this is as it's not like ver there's no
hard or sound on the inside it's just
you you almost don't hear it yeah you
always know where this is de moivre's
theorem it's a very special case because
it's special it does come up repeatedly
in fact you'll see it appear next has
one point two you can take quite
significant advantage of it now before I
on before I let you do this just to
finish working okay
I wonder based on what is generalizing
we have done okay I wonder what she
would make off you remember how I said
okay what happens when we do repeated
multiplication white line what do you
think would happen if I did repeated
multiplication by something like - I
don't shout it out just trim picture
what might be happening
now to guide you before I just wore it
for you to guide you let me remind you
where is to eye on our complex plane
it's still on the imaginary axis is no
real part to it okay but if I is here
then - I is twice as far away it's up
here there's two eye so I hope you can
see now to get this in one art form you
can see what the argument is and you can
see what the modulus is okay so now what
would you predict would happen when you
multiply by two I repeatedly are you
ready for the picture just think about
it
I'm gonna start nice and small okay if I
plot one and I plot it like there I need
to start small and I hope you can see
why okay well the first multiplication
by 2i that's easy I've already shown you
where that is okay so that's 1 then 1 2
there will be 2 I'm you see that here's
my first modification what will happen
for the next one ok firstly I'm gonna
rotate back onto the real axis right but
I'm gonna be 3/4 twice as far away you
see that what happens when I do my
another pilot Iranians if I multiplied
one more times it's okay because it's 2i
and 2i ^ 4 of course is 2 to the 4 times
I before but you know what item 4 it is
it's 1 so it's just 16 back back of the
real axis
oh sure get a sense by the geometry of
these numbers ok these are very powerful
results but you need to see them
if you're like I feel like I've tried
I've tried and I've tried and it still
sound like an idiot
they just call it that okay save
yourself some trouble
let me let me tell you will see the
fridge guy our games or do Baba okay
please don't please don't
as um as I've heard many well-meaning
people say don't pronounce this as okay
now I hope you say it but they say it
with great authority in like this
commentator and they say yeah yeah yeah
I know that is the boy French term right
now it's French
it's not Spanish okay it's not like oh
yeah oh yeah
this chili and midnight not Spanish
it's French compadre